pascal beaucoup de socios qui parlent
d'amour
alors on a demandé aux chroniqueurs des
anecdotes les concernant sur l'amour à
leur apparaît sur l'écran et tu vas pas
savoir à quel aparté tu vas devoir
trouver à qui appartiennent ces
anecdotes
alors attention c'est parti envoyez les
anecdotes vous jouez également chez vous
http amour c'est parti on envoie les
anecdotes
alors je me suis fait relooker par amour
j'ai payé une opération de chirurgie
esthétique par amour j'ai eu un coup de
foudre pour le rendre meilleur ami de
mon ex m'a propriétaire m'a surpris en
train de faire l'amour par amour j'ai
fait tokyo new york pour un réveillon
j'ai fait 400 kilomètres pour rencontrer
l'amant de la femme c'est sûr pour la
saint-valentin g privatiser la première
classe d'un avion ça sert j'ai fait
l'amour avec la mauvaise personne
ça c'est de l'ormeau mon ex à draguer
mon frère alors qu'on était encore
ensemble ça ça doit être maxime qui dit
alors les shihri qui à ton avis on va on
va démarrer par une histoire conscient
de ce que je me suis fait rouler coups
apparemment je m'en tape un peu j'ai
fait 400 kilomètres pour rencontrer
l'amant de ma femme 400 qui démêle peut
rencontrer la demande ma femme de ma
femme je connais pas les réponses moi
mais moi je pense que moi qui aurai plus
vers le vers le mali j'irai euros le
routier c'est vrai lorsque routier je te
jure je connais ce que c'est toi t'es
sûr à lui il a pris le qatar
alors déjà on apprend tout ça à
l'antenne que ta femme a un amant écoute
les sols se sont elles seraient bien sûr
et bon alors voilà pour mes 30 ans elle
voulait me faire une surprise à vous les
invitez tous mes potes surprise normal
et moi je pars à l'entraînement de foot
et je vois un texto d'un mec nico je
fais c'est keith nico pas encore quand
tu pourras aller devant tant il ya 13
ans et je passe devant téléphone et je
vois un texto nico je fus nico nico c
koi nico c'est quoi ces textos là et je
l'appelle et nico il sait que j'appelle
moi je ne sais pas que je suis en train
de la pluie et toi qu'est ce tu vas
faire chaud au relais en question à
faire je fais quoi je vais pas
l'entraînement foot revenir sur chariot
je vais découpé en morceaux qui arrête
de te raconter déjà d'une prime à prague
où tu te raconte unis mais vient grande
gueule lui les à l'ancienne dans le 78
il est mort de réelles et chez lui
rigole il est mort de rire et je prends
la voiture et me donne rendez-vous à
relent et je prends ma voiture et je
vais à orléans une farlane dit un
baltringue rendent chez toi rentre chez
toi arrête atteint battre aix et nicolas
et m'a appris que c'est nicolas donc
c'est pas l'avant de ma femme mais j'ai
fait 400 bornes pour rien quoi alors
qu'ils accomplissaient nicolas enfin
l'histoire à lapins poules avait fait
une connerie
[Musique]
vous me penserez ont enlevé aux rémois
des anecdotes compris sur un terrain
pour ckoi mais avec quoi n'inquiète pas
je suis tunisien c'est bon allez on y va
alors me ferait penser non c'est une
cata alors autre chose qui apparemment
j'ai fait tokyo new york pour un
réveillon mais carrément j'ai fait tokyo
ne payons pas moi c'est pas toi tokyo
new york s'est saisi
j'ai fait un truc de mannequin c'est
beau quoi tu as fait nous dit tout à
l'heure
folle amoureuse d'un d'un mannequin
américain pourrait s'appeler à new york
qui s'appelait stew gentioux syrte car
tu vois ses frères de johnatan il
travaillait dans l'avion s'il est en
fait que j'étais donc à tokyo et j'ai
pris ce vol est malheureusement il y
avait une tempête de neige sur new york
donc l'avion a dû aller à philadelphie à
l'époque et j'ai passé le réveillon à
l'aéroport de sylla des pros avec la
neige avec la neige prévues des boules
mais les boules de l'ain
[Applaudissements]
ça allait bouger
j'ai eu un coup de foudre pour le
meilleur ami de mon ex s'agirait de
leurs mots d'argot non plus mais j'ai eu
un coup de foudre pour le meilleur ami
de mon ex j'ai dit moi je verrais bien
kelly à quoi tu parles je la sens comme
ça je vous jure que je ne réponds je te
le jure je ne connais pas les réponses
je vous le jure que non mais je sens les
trucs lui je vois il a fait 400 km marin
compresseur soir j'ai dit tokyo balles
carrées vous je suis amoureuse de
l'amour pour le meilleur ami de votre ex
aequo leur jeu seront pas testés lors
d'un mariage
ouais il est arrivé en vo de soirée et
puis je les regardais puis m'a regardé
on est un coup de foudre mais vraiment
mais un truc de dingue
j'étais choquée s'apprend fois que
j'essaie de ma vie est en fait il
s'avère que il habitait en face de
l'arrêt de bus de mon ex donc tous les
jours quand je prenais bus pour aller
chez mon ex sergent que c'est une
histoire
[Rires]
vous avez pensé à tout vous avez pensé
associer votre comme vous l'aurez donc
l'histoire ou les locaux il arrive de
temps en temps que je le vois à star et
du slam savais que j'allais voir mon sa
connaissance à l'arrêt de bus non elle
toutefois
ah ouais je me suis rendu compte que
j'aimais vraiment mon mec on a laissé
tomber cette histoire mais ouais mais
l'histoire plus astérix en fait alors on
va vous demander de voter pour
l'histoire la plus pourrie amour pour y
voilà a mûri pour vous nous dites merci
qui dit alors attention on va prendre
aller pour la saint-valentin g
privatiser la première classe d'un avion
moi je pense ça marque toutefois pascal
veut ludique et si oui il ya bien
longtemps
ouais ouais donc c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était alors c'était tourneur c'est
une histoire quand tu crées huissier ah
bon les u6 et ça c'est quand j'avais un
peu un peu d'argent c'était très très
content c'est rigolo
voilà et donc j'ai fait en fait c'était
à los angeles new york était vraiment
blindés oui vraiment débat était blindée
et à tête rouge nous a dit je t'ai pas
flambeur vous n'avez pas marqué un truc
quoi tf1 il avait les yeux grands
ouverts
c'était pour voir losail le savez moi
j'ai pas vu depuis longtemps mais c'est
vrai qu'on doit rien alors alors à côté
nous racontez vous voilà donc j'étais
sûr fait j'étais avec une jeune femme
alors le problème c'est que ça devait se
passer pendant un mariage cette histoire
de pas donner de date
et donc j'étais vous étiez marié je
pense je ne sais pas et donc j'ai donc
j'ai fait un new york los angeles et ta
femme elle a fait saint valentin tout
seul
ballet l'était pas visiblement avec moi
je pense ne fut pas celle que vous avez
pris baptisée pallas était un petit ap
c'était un petit avion parce que s'il
n'y avait que quatre places en fait de
tous et donc j'ai cherché des quatre
places pour être tranquille de c'était
bien c'était à west est très sympa ça et
vous avez changé de place gênant gêne en
fait nan bon on a fait en fait deux
grands lycées rien c'est des mecs qui
passent on a fait venir est pas comment
ils également chauffeur rugby
quand j'ai du coup on a allongé des
sièges et c'était assez c'était un papa
maman ou en avion oui je pense
la sucré ou salé alors ça dépend des
parfois sucre et des c'est vraiment
c'est quoi c'est pourquoi je suis dans
l'avion j'ai la mienne sexuelle à cela
on est une émission familiale salle est
très sympa les chéris moi j'aimerais
bien savoir ccp une opération de
chirurgie esthétique pas bon c'est quoi
la remplacer
j'ai payé une opération de chirurgie
esthétique gravement on va le savoir
dans un instant jean lui seul on était
dans l'amour et c'est vrai que pascal a
pensé que c'était vous qui avez fait une
opération de chirurgie esthétique pas
l'amour est ce que c'est vrai ou pas
c'est exact exact s'il se passait alors
on prend un but c'est à dire que j'ai
toujours il est depuis la tendre enfance
j'ai une tendresse particulière pour les
poitrines
si j'avais laissé si on m'avait laissé
faire jouer et et à ma mère que l'entrée
en sixième a été obligée de me freiner
c'est pas j'adorais tu es d et es et moi
je m'étais tous les jours mais jusqu'à
6e m'arrêter avant voilà et donc du coup
ça continue a l'air intéressant où
j'avais je sortais une fille donc cédé
13 amoureux qui accompagnent ces sur la
taille de sa poitrine
je me suis donc porté volontaire pour le
financer cette opération là et
malheureusement ça s'est mal terminée
parce qu'elle a fait l'opération
elle est partie avec le chirurgien est
partie que les sa lé pas partie ça oui
ça 95 fcp a pris avec un jeu vous savez
on met des bandages pour fait mal etc
elle a retiré au bout de quinze journées
de les bandages donc pour j'ai regardé
les résultats vont pas j'ai touché elle
a dit à i elle m'a quitté le lendemain
[Applaudissements]
je ne fais jamais janus cette séquence
'cela ne l'eau chaude oublier allez on
passe à autre chose
on va regarder l'histoire vous bon match
elle est bien l écrit nous sauver cette
séquence pascal juste avant est ce que
toi tu avais est ce que tu as fait un
truc de ouf
apparemment par amour non pas des papas
des choses comme ça pas les choses comme
ça monte ça toujours c'est toujours
resté juste et rationnel bardon
rationnelle oui simple c'est un pur et
simple des fleurs dès lors des voyages
des choses comme ça c'est quoi moi ça
lui aussi des fleurs et des tanks donc
point commun avec pascal je vais donner
un show en province en histoire il a eu
juste eu chaud il n'y avait pas la clim
donc voilà d'autres écoles donc je
faisais un book inn en boîte de nuit
[Rires]
effectivement pendant la boîte de nuit
j'anime un petit peu il ya un garçon
extrêmement jolie et sympathique qui
vient me voir on c'est rare que ça se
fasse mais vraiment il est très mignon
lui donne mon numéro de téléphone jeudi
à quel hôtel j'étais et je lui dis coûte
au moins 6 et on ne se reverra pas donc
si c'est que du sexe ont fait un petit
jeu quand arrive je vous la porte de
l'hôtel va de ma chambre tu rentre
directement et je serai dans la chambre
je t'attends dans noir j'aime bien ça me
dit que tu es un pont pour vois pas ce
qu'on fait au niveau sensations j'aimais
versants et ça devient très peur c'est
ce plan les judokas suite d'histoires à
côté mais là on parle alors parler
d'amour ça se transforme en train photo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est de donner du plaisir aux fans dont
ceux là c'était arrivé mon désir c'est
bien donc la personne qui l'a prêté du
soleil les moments un texto coucou
j'arrive dessine de mieux en faire nous
fait que le toit de cet honneur
[Rires]
je laisse la porte entrouverte yves à
côté un peu interdisent à ses portes
ouvertes de la chambre shia bloc qu'une
[ __ ] poubelle mais ça n'a aucun intérêt
je vais dans ma chambre du conapp et ça
coûte et oui c'était une suite et du
coup je suis dans le noir et j'attends
tout d'un coup j'entends la porte qui
grince entre la personne et là on
commence à faire l'amour mais vraiment
l'amour comme des personnes qui ne se
connaissent pas mon qui se lâche et qui
donne tout c'est les interdits dans le
noir et les interdits de la non
connaissance sur les box horrible ça il
se fait vraiment ça se passe très très
bien je vous dis quand même c'est rare
d'avant j'étais rarement que des fans
est vraiment la personne est blessée
quand on voit ça suffit maintenant et
tout d'un coup ça frappe à la porte
[ __ ] là vraiment je lis sur possible
cdu c'est à dire combien personne ne
passait pas c'était pas aidé à faire
disparaître le room service j'ai pas
comme l'état et comme 3 heures du matin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bah oui oui alors oui vous me direz
pascal si cette histoire alors oui ça
vous est déjà arrivé
non ce n'est pas ça je me lève j'étais
troisième fois je dis mon invité écoute
attend moi s'il te plait je sais pas
arrêter genre là vous voyez rien mais
attendez dans le noir je lèverai de ça
mais elle est beaucoup de vagues ont
tout raconté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça qu'elle est intéressant
bah oui alors je me lève je me mets à
déshabiller
je me déshabille la perla balawi alors
oui j'y vais j'y vais de ce pas un peu
agacé je vous la force bam sur qui je
tombe donc oui bah mon p'tit mec est
toujours des textos avec lui dit viens
de rejoindre l'as encore et les nazis je
regarde la télé donc ils étaient deux
dans le dos et dans ces boule et bill
mais le ghana qui dans mon lit et celui
à qui j'ai donné rendez-vous pour baiser
dans le noir et d irak avez vous
quelques mois pour pour se rencontrer
mais c'est qu'est ce que tu fais là il
me dit ma vie à me rejoindre à porte
sera ouverte
mais jc balbala je retourne dans la
chambre et là je mais c'est pas possible
ça se trouve c'est en train de faire
l'amour à une horreur intégral je ne
sais pas qui je suis amour joue la porte
est effectivement alors comme c'est
souvent le cas avec les moches ta
personne très très bien avant joue la
porte
pas top j'en lis mais c'est pas non plus
horribles et du coup j'espère gardois
devient un de la boîte de nuit deux
personnes
et comme un symbole c'est gentil rien
moi j'ai pas posé de question donc du
coup jacques goujat
donc du coup l'autre moniba énervé je
repars banon je suis pas un goujat donc
la fin je vous la fais pas passer mon
allergie ou non du on est rendu alors on
n'a pas sauvé la série géniale c'est bon
de la vie auquel on ne s'attend pas
ces imprévus mémoire vous allez recevoir
une lettre de marc aubry choses de la
vie ça